folks
it's joe derosa from the taste buds
podcast please come see me live i will
be performing in philadelphia
pennsylvania at the punchline comedy
club this coming march you can get
tickets to that on my website
joederosainfo.com also right after that
i'm going to south by southwest and
doing some food related shows down there
so come check me out there i'll also be
doing some regular stand-up stuff too so
if you live in austin come see me at
those shows in april i'm going back
not back no in april where am i wait i'm
going west in april boys i'm going to
the irvine improv uh right outside of la
and then i'm going down to san diego to
do some shows again tickets available
for these shows for all my shows coming
up may back in austin at the creek and
cave june fort collins at the comedy
fort all of the tickets are available at
joederosainfo.com
and if you're in new york come to joey
rose's bar and sandwich shop open six
days a week now tuesday through sunday
opening at 12 p.m every day come get a
sandwich and an affordable delicious
beverage
come see us joeyrosesnyc.com
what's up everybody let's talk tour
dates real quick this coming week i will
be in madison and chicago that's
february 26th and 27th uh at the
barrymore theater and the vic theater
those are on sale right now we have sold
out the first shows second show still
tickets available and i have just
announced all these dates they're
currently on sale right now these are
new dates april 15th in louisville april
16th in evansville april 23rd in tulsa
april 24th in oklahoma city june 10th in
rochester june 11th in syracuse june
17th in milwaukee june 18th in
minneapolis and june 24th in hampton
beach also of course the big show the
new york show the hometown show the only
one i've ever done here is the beacon
theater on may 14th every one of those
dates available right now at
savolcanocomedy.com thank you
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right
howdy everybody welcome to t-a-s-t-e
buds i'm joe i'm sal here we go here we
go here we go candy battle today sort of
candy battle candy versus cookie
cookie versus candy everything is upside
down this is chaos both have a fish uh
both have a oh you're doing fish two
weeks in a row almost oh yeah swedish
fish bolted today both of today have an
animal theme yeah yeah you are battling
the animal cracker yeah we're battling
for the animal and i am defending the
swedish fish yeah two
treats that uh might have started off in
our childhood but certainly people enjoy
them as they get to be adults too
both have a little kitsch to them
absolutely one is a candy and one is a
cookie absolutely they have a lot of
similarities and a lot of differences we
thought to make a good match-up all
right so it's gonna be a good one how
are you feeling so i feel
okay
in what respect
mentally no good okay you're okay why
we were talking about it earlier i was
just trying to make small talk on the
show no i'm not good
i don't know
i will i'm on uh i'd switch to
wellbutrin
oh yeah yeah and
i don't know so far so good it seems
like it's okay that should be the
commercial
yeah that's funny wellbutrin so far so
good
yeah i don't know it's it's definitely
i'm on the wellbutch yeah yeah that's
why i bring it up yeah yeah we both
switched sort of recently i didn't
switch from anything i was okay i wasn't
taking anything uh and i just was like
man i'm going through uh something i
could use a little help maybe and then
my doc who i i trust i went to high
school with him
shout out to me
he said uh let me try this and see how
you like it i had talked to a couple
friends that didn't said they enjoyed it
so i enjoyed it but like it was working
for them yeah i don't know
oh we're talking medication
antidepressants
see what does anxiety are
it was also anxiety right yeah
antidepressants yeah i was on prozac
and i'm in the last week of
transitioning for the pros and cons
yeah that was failing
there was a while where it worked great
and then i mean
i keep talking to my therapist about
this and saying like i can't tell what's
a real
like problem that i'm having in my head
versus
this is just fallout from the awful two
years that's been happening it's true
you know what i mean it's like
everything is so mixed up i can't you
know it's hard it's very hard can i say
i don't want to change the topic we stay
right where we are but i just don't want
to forget this because i forgot last
episode
kedoba boom
i cannot get enough of that i snipped it
and i watch it i've watched it 300 times
already
it's impossible not to you it is the
funniest thing and i already people
sounding off in the comments two weeks
ago cadoba boom has by the way
apparently it's kudoba
which is my whole entire life i thought
it was cadoba
that's what i thought you know the cake
you know i heart
i just but apparently it's q doba and
people were like that's so funny they
saying cadoba but i have played that
thing in my i walk around the house
going kadoba boom
it is so if you guys saw two weeks ago
when we did uh chipotle versus
chick-fil-a and i i challenged joe to
name another place that he would get a a
a a burrito from and feel good about it
that was fast casual and his answer was
cadoba boom
yeah um
people seem to be enjoying it i i had no
idea i had no idea i said i want to put
it on merch
yes let's see what it says
qdoba
all right oh is is that what does qdoba
mean
oh oh so i thought it was some for some
reason i thought it was a definition
because they have up the pronunciation
thing that they put up when you're
looking up a
a word
uh it's an acronym
stands for queso delicious on basically
anything come on no way
no way is that true is that true no it's
not an acronym at all it says it says
that was
that was the joke and then it was the
cordoba just stands for flavor
it was a campaign where they were making
people think it was an acronym oh okay
well uh i was like let's put it on merch
speaking of that yeah
fans let us know do you want a kadoba
boom t-shirt
or that would be a good that would be a
good okay so that's so so here's what's
coming out
hopefully in a week we're just waiting
on well
okay so we're getting two
old-school starter caps and actually
it's this version this old school
starter cap right here
uh which if you're our age especially
this was they had every team and with
this exact font with the script
underneath you're getting
one that says t-a-s-t-e on top and buds
in script that's uh gonna be black and
gold i believe and then we got the nyx
colors which is like that royal blue and
orange islanders met and that's gonna
say the god damn and underneath will say
girls and it'll be an embroidered girl
scouts girl scouts yeah and it'll be
embroidered just like that that's two
pieces of the merch one will be a heart
uh but the line in the heart is actually
the words no matter what happens i love
you yes and then in the middle it has
the acronym for no matter what happens i
love you it's pretty cool it's like
right on the chest plate almost like a
superman yes uh or no it's actually
bigger than that and then uh we have
another one of joe and i
uh
and if again if you know this it was
really popular it's like there was these
nba style graphic tees yes back in like
the late 80s early 90s with like big
head caricatures it was like bobble head
pictures before bobble heads were a
thing it was a caricature artist
yeah and uh that was big back then like
nba jam yeah they picked like two
players yeah over jordan had one but
they put two players on a shirt we kind
of are mimicking that and joe and i will
be in taste buds uniforms and uh with
big heads and it's that's gonna be one
thing that we're waiting on i'm still
waiting on the art to come in for that
uh
yeah one or two or three other items but
uh
hoodie with the spray painted uh the old
old school boardwalk spray painted taste
buds on it
uh and that's it i think it and it's a
shoelace or some socks some shoelaces
let's say no matter
if you want it on something let us know
stickers we got we you know but that
would be another good starter cap
cadoba boom that's what i'm saying yeah
that's yeah that'd be a great starter i
love it are we allowed to just print
cadoba on stuff is it is cordoba
theirs or is it the spice can imagine
it's a word is it a word i don't know
i think like would i could i could i
drop it on scrabble
can i drop skidobe on scrabble
well they said it means flavor there's a
scrapbook dictionary let me know
um
what is your ghoul
cadoba a real word
it's a mexican grill it says
just put kedober definition
it yeah but that all that comes up is
their thing i think it's crossed between
like adobe
a a dope
uh what is it goya adobo adobo i'll tell
you what we could do folks
i'll tell you what we could do is it not
i can't read that no i'm not saying it's
a mashup of two words
but i'll tell you what we could do
because some fans are laughing at my
mispronunciation because i say kedoba
it's supposed to be q doba
we could spell out
k a like
right doba yes boom yeah we could do
that and then that's a little inside
wink then you gotta really be in the
know
what does that mean kadoba boom what
does that mean yeah you gotta really be
in the now yeah that's kind of cool i
will show you one more thing i got of my
merch here
i'm wearing it right now again didn't
want my name on the thing so i got a
little old-school sv on there
and then on the back
what do you think i love it
try to didn't you show this on the show
already did i i think you did
oh all right because i just got this one
in so i was like i love it i'm supposed
to get one before i leave
why do i feel like i won't fit the large
i have an xl maybe i gotta stop
i gotta get my [ __ ] together man did i
show you the nicholas cage one no all
right there's another there's another
shirt with an inclusion let's get into
this
this way you can put nicholas cage on a
shirt but we can't put the doughnuts
it's my face because they said you got
to sell them with your face and i said
who's going to buy one with my face
nicholas cage i said a guy is going to
buy one of my face which may be women
but aren't i eliminating half the people
i don't know i i couldn't wear something
with my face on it and they said trust
us we know from we do this merch if you
put your face on it it'll sell more than
anything else that's what people want so
i got a picture of my face and i just
put nicolas cage underneath it
all right
because i couldn't take it seriously i
gotta sell my face seriously all right
all right i don't understand but sure
from a movie or just
no just like the nate the words nicholas
cage onto my
face right
that's weird it is that's why i made it
weird because i couldn't i couldn't take
it seriously
swedish fish oreo yeah disgusting by the
way if you're trying before we start
here make sure to hit that subscribe
button make sure to hit like
uh download the audio versions of the
podcast if you like to listen uh you can
subscribe to those on apple podcasts and
all that app on apple spotify everything
can you rate us on apple that's what we
really we need you to rate us on apple
and subscribe to us on the tube on the
youtube
all right here we go uh before we get
into the battle just a a few little
interesting tidbits regarding these
foods we've we found a swedish fish
oreo that sounds disgusting i heard
about it i i haven't tried if it was in
front of me i would try it because it's
it makes me so curious
but he actually wrote a little review if
you're curious
swedish fish oreo review mini this is uh
someone on what instagram
socal snack hunter okay somebody youtube
it's a mini review it's not a review of
oreo minis um so uh sweetest sweet
swedish fish oreo mini review i got
quite a few pm's this morning what's a
p.m private message isn't that a dm i
don't know maybe it's english
asking how these were and quite honestly
we aren't a huge fan of them swedish
fish gummies the cream seems to have a
different consistency than other oreos
almost a waxy paste taste wise you can
really taste the swedish fish cream
after getting pasta chocolate wafer in
closing this wasn't our favorite oreo
cookie and we wouldn't miss it if this
was discontinued lol that's under that's
not a glowing review
who does flavors don't go together i
know when i look at it and i go maybe
they're trying to peak our curiosity
which they did
but what is the flavor of the swedish
fish why are they swedish
is that what they invented to find out
it was
the swedes invented the swedish fish
for some reason i never really thought
that that's why they were called that
uh
lingenberry a european berry that is
interesting the red swedish fish
is often considered a berry flavor even
though many think it's cherry
uh
i mean in my book you the the red is the
only red i mean i mean the flavor i mean
i'm not doing the multi colors are there
other flavors yeah they have like
multi-colored never heard of
yeah i'm not into it i like the i like
the one and what year were they invented
pimp
yeah let's get into a little bit of
backstory on these things please because
i am interested in both products
late 1950s swedish candy manufacturer
malaco began exporting their wine gum
and licorice-based sweets in north
america their fish-shaped candies or
swedish fish were a hit and took off in
the u.s markets in the 1960s and 70s
they are manufactured by the same
company they make sour patch kids yeah
baby i knew i was on the right side of
history here
they come in different sizes and flavors
yes that is true sometimes i do like one
of those bigger ones
um seven thousand metric tons are made
of it a year what is a metric ton
it says its equivalent weight of nearly
two thousand orca whales wow wait i
thought a ton was two thousand pounds
so a metric ton how much did 2000 orca
whales way
let's see what a metric ton is just then
we'll come back to this
oh yeah okay it is okay
all right so that means
how many orca whales well an orca whale
probably weighs about a ton
but didn't it say it weighs as much what
about as two thousand whales
oh seven thousand electrical seven
thousand so so what orca whale weighs a
little more than
two thousand pounds wait am i doing that
right no i don't know
wait no i'm doing this right i feel like
i'm in freaking uh
who cares anyway
yeah reedus has i did it wrong rita's
has a swedish fish flavored water ice
uh
in they also go by the name
pastel fiscar in sweden
uh which translates to pale colored fish
you can try a black herring
wow
a salty a salty black licorice flavor
called the black herring fish are
beloved by sweden but never quite took
off here packaging return items
with candy allegedly can get you faster
service the swedish fish theory is a con
concept that went viral on reddit
claiming that you can get faster service
if your ship
if you ship return items with a package
of swedish fish
that's interesting
wow basically the idea is that a
personal gesture thanking a repairman
could go a long way so you might get
creamed in this one
i didn't know swedish fish had this kind
of i didn't know they sold them in
assorted yeah looking at an orange
yellow and a green right in front of me
and this is the first time my eyes have
ever seen that
i i didn't know they had this kind of
reach i thought this was a little bit
like this they got fish tails
i'm sorry i don't not see these products
on shelves
look at this they got tropicals they're
going like skittles is this is this are
they going hard in the paint now or is
this an old article
wow crap crushed fruit
crushed fruit mixed deets you might be
in trouble here dude swedish fish is
getting their hands at a lot of other
products
you know this one upstream babe
yeah you might be you might be in
trouble here that's from just last year
2021 so
okay so swedish i'll tell you i'll tell
you this is the one thing though no
matter what you do no matter what you
say to me swedish fish wait don't start
going in we got to go backstory on
animal crackers now
an animal
the animal crackers that were familiar
we asked you a question do you remember
anything we do previously on the show or
do you just
or is it is it like a new is this like
uh you know uh one of those movies where
adam sandler falls in love with drew
barrymore every day he can't remember
the fish and i had something to say
about it i did 40 first dates over i
didn't think we were not going to go to
the animal crackers i just no i know but
it was you even said it was your id you
go let's get backstory before we battle
then you leaned in to start battling and
i had to tell you not to do it i don't
know if i said before we battle i just
said let's get backstage we didn't do
the chat you forgot the chance last
episode but i'm not even getting into a
battle i'm just gonna i was gonna say
something about save it for the battle
okay that way you don't repeat yourself
four times in the battle because you're
out of material okay how about that
material do you prep yours no i'm just
saying you know you only have so many
points in you and then you start
repeating those points well when you
when you make me take a pull of sativa
that's true i didn't make you do
anything you told me to relax take the
edges off listen baby had a rough day if
it was up to me i'd be blowing lines of
devil's dandruff right now
[Music]
you know i have respect for this work i
don't come in here all tooted up devil's
dandruff
i've never heard of devils
devil's dandruff
all right the animal crackers that we're
familiar with today were first made in
england in the mid-1800s interesting so
both of these foods not uh not native to
the americas they were slightly sweet
biscuits shaped like animals for a while
they imported to the united states but
in 1871 the df stouffer biscuit company
in york pennsylvania started producing
guess who's from york
guess who's from york you
almost
i'm from about an hour away from york i
mean so am i
no
york pennsylvania yeah that's like right
near where i grew up all right but i'm
like an hour away from that you know who
it actually is there you can't say guess
where i'm from and it's an hour away
that's lunacy
we love butcher box we love butcher box
we love butcher box we've told you about
butcher box we've screamed it at you if
you're not doing it at this point it's
your own fault meal prepping is
difficult it's hard you don't have the
time butcher box is a subscription
service that takes the guesswork out of
finding high quality meat butcher box
sources their meat from their partners
and with the highest standards of
quality there's no more searching at the
grocery store for 100 grass-fed beef or
the free-range organic chicken or the
wild-caught seafood and by the way
probably paying way too much for it when
you finally find it all right i love
butcher boxes steaks it makes me feel
okay about eating steak when i'm eating
steak i know that it is the cleanest
purest healthiest version of steak i
could possibly eat for the most
affordable price i love it i love it i
love that they're carrying fish i love
that they have the free-range chicken i
just i it it's it's it's high quality
meat and protein that you can cook at
home and afford to bring into your home
it's very convenient also i don't have
time to want to go out and like stock my
my freezer with all the proteins you
know what i mean yeah and then also go
and look at the meats and like have to
decide you know it that's a long process
yeah no it's you click a box it comes if
you don't want it you hit stop that's it
that's it especially if you got a big
family or a single person either way
you're always loaded up and you never
have to run around last minute and get
anything no antibiotics no added
hormones each box contains 8 to 14
pounds of meat depending on which box
you choose of course that's enough for
24 meals it's packed fresh it's shipped
frozen for convenience you get it you
toss it right in the freezer you thought
out when you're ready to do it and mimic
your own box or you can go with one of
theirs i usually customize but i will
say here's the big thing they give away
ready
this is your chance to have to never
shop for ground beef again okay butcher
box is giving new members free ground
beef for life sign up at butcherbox.com
taste buds and get two pounds of ground
beef free
every order for life of your membership
every single order so log on to
butcherbox.com taste buds to claim the
deal try it out guys
let's talk noom folks uh you know look
there's a lot of restrictive diets out
there there are a lot of workout
programs that you start and
they're too daunting you kind of start
down the road and it gets too hard and
that was that's what leads to you
quitting the diet or falling off of the
workout routine or both
uh what is noom though well boom is a
psychology uh based approach to weight
loss yes unlike uh well the psychology
approach is based on scientifically
proven principles like cognitive
behavioral therapy which helps people
better understand their relationship
with food and why they eat the way they
eat
yeah and that's the point is noom is
going to help you do this
the right way for you the most effective
way for you more than 75 of their users
complete the program and why are they
doing it that way for you because of
this psychological approach that they
take with it uh an off day is totally
okay it's not going to set you like way
off course yeah
yeah exactly it's about just progress
just stay the course if you if you if
you mess up one day you just get back on
the horse by the way it's all grounded
in science which is great uh you know
and they have more than uh they've
published more than 30 peer-reviewed
scientific articles that inform users
practitioners scientists
and the public about how their methods
work and how effective they are more
than 60 percent of users lose 5 or more
of the body weight by
16 weeks which is amazing and more than
60
of users engaged in the program they
keep the weight off for more than a year
so you get the app you get the app and
you can decide how long you want to stay
on the app yeah that's what's good about
it too it's not like a commitment you
want to stay on the app five minutes 10
minutes 20 minutes you get the app and
you decide how much you are doing it per
day yeah so sign up for your trial
get psychology-based support and
motivation to reach your goals at
noom.com taste bud
singular n-o-o-m.com
taste bud and sign up for your trial my
sister is using this now she's loving it
and she's trying to get me to use it so
i've been talking to her about it and i
honestly think i'm going to download the
app and and just give it a try noom.com
tastebud
interestingly enough both of these can
uh both of these items are not were not
made here
uh as early as the 1800s animal-shaped
cookies uh were being devoured across
the pond they became so popular that
americans wanted a piece too and
stateside bakers began experimenting
with their own recipes the earliest
known of the so-called animal recipes to
pop up was in the 1870s publication
called secrets of the bakers and
confectioners trade so swedish fish and
animal crackers are both coming in
around the same time they're both 1800s
and mid to late 1800s
there are many manufacturers well
there's only one i love the term animal
crack i will say i don't like all animal
crackers like sometimes they sell them
in a big tub
yeah and they're like and the ones in
the big tub that they sell like you know
costco or something like that are def
different than the ones that come the
ones i'm rocking right now are nabisco's
barnums
yeah they're the most popular that is
the quintessential box right there tiger
lion a polar bear and a bison you don't
see bison behind bars and zeus
i think you do don't you bison
no that seems crazy that's like they're
making it look like a monkey cage though
that a bison is in
how was one of those things not a monkey
and all right how is one of those things
not a monkey right yeah animal crackers
you don't know why lion and tiger
definitely behind bars i don't normally
see bison behind bars um now here's the
okay
okay so we have enough how many how many
i want to read more about the animal
crack okay
uh in 1902 nabisco began selling what
they called barnum's animals that's see
i always thought i had to do a barnum
and bailey surf circus yeah
his greatest showman pt barnum i wonder
if he got paid for that the circus steam
crackers were the first to be sold in
small snack size packages before then
all crackers were sold in bulk from a
barrel this is where the term cracker
barrel comes from oh you know that all
right
okay the original barnum's carton was
intended as a christmas ornament oh
that's cool that's why it's got the
little handle on it yeah that's cool the
familiar circus train package oh it's a
circus train with its bottom wheels and
handle on the top has been in place
since the bisco been manufacturing that
more than a hundred years ago originally
conceived as a christmas gift turned
ornament i mean who the hell is going to
fit polish off a box of cookies and then
hang that box from the tree
i gotta tell you i can't believe it
never occurred to me yet until now
[Music]
i actually it warms my heart the package
is meant to be hung on a tree by its
string at the time
boxes of barnum's animal crackers cults
cost five cents
each year eight thousand miles of string
are used in packaging wow
each shift at nabisco's new jersey
factory used approximately 30 miles of
string for the handles at the top of the
carton translates to 8 000 miles of
string a year the crackers are kept in a
300 foot long oven
for about 4 minutes which means they're
baked at a rate of 12 000 a minute wow
so what let's whoa there have been 54
animals reimagined this cracker okay i
didn't know that it's a virtual zoo out
there baby
barnum's came to have developed the most
animals of any brand with 37 different
creatures over the years today a two
ounce box of barnums contains 22
crackers featuring 19 different animals
so the four on the front are not the
only shapes you get oh the latest one is
a koala it was chosen by popular vote
in 2002. else this might be an old
article but the appearance of animals
have changed over time until 58 animal
shapes were stamped from a dough sheet
by cookie cutters which produced
outlines but they were rudimentary after
rotary dyes were installed the cookies
became much more distinct with engraved
designs that revealed
a surprising amount of detail the rotary
dies is still used today
the monkey has been the only animal to
wear clothes
all right
so
pimp before we go into the battle one
more thing what how much these are sold
every year wait look at that that last
one
in 1990s a promotion encouraged kids to
chomp on endangered species
every child goes for the head first
which was the nabisco execs
which was what nabisco execs were
counting on when they revealed a special
endangered collection of barnum and
barnum's animal crackers in 1995 to
benefit the world world wildlife fund
it's the 16 at-risk animals featured
limited edition
jungle motif box komodo dragons uh
peregrine peregrine
peregrine falcons uh hawaii was this
benefiting how was this good for the
world wildlife
fund
what do people like about animal
crackers biting off their heads our hope
is that children will line up match them
and buy okay i thought they were going
to say it was a bad uh
it was a bad thing to have people
chomping on endangered species
no
all right babe all right pimp how many
animal crackers sold in a year
versus swedish fish
40 million packs
each year
all right
that's wild it says all right well it
says there's a there's a story behind it
behind the snack a long-running story
i'd love to hear you read directly from
her website more
it's riveting well i'd love to hear dead
air more for when you ask for some type
of stat
well i mean you know but we this is a
thing we do you know all right ready
i can tell you wanted me to stop reading
yeah about two bullet points maybe it
was going on and on i know but i i i
it's been so long since we gave a i felt
like there's been a dearth of
information about the products i agree i
agree i agree and somebody's got to do
it somebody's got to do it 14.27
billion swedish fish
are sold that's a lot that's a lot
that's a lot of fish sales
that's a lot of two for everyone on the
planet maybe yeah all right
uh they're right ranked is the tenth
most popular movie candy swedish fish
are the 19th most popular halloween
candy they were my number one when those
things got dropped in my bag i was
thrilled what else do the swedes do well
you know
they do they do furniture well sweden
and sweden yeah also the watch no that's
switzerland swiss yes do you mix up the
switz and the swedes because i do all
the time i do
couldn't tell you if i was in one place
or the other what the difference would
be
i think sweden is more like a s
i don't know joe
all right let's start the battle ready
yeah
all right here we go ready
[Laughter]
i love you look at me i know no matter
what happens i love you no matter what
happens i love you all right here we go
b-a-t-t-l-e bunch all right here we go
well here's something we never do let's
start with some comments from the fans
okay are you kidding once you're over
age 25 the swedish fish is not worth the
trip to the dentist i agree i was gonna
say before i'll give you one thing you
could tell me the laundry list of things
you like about swedish fish and i look
at you and i don't have to say a word
wait pimp don't scroll yet go ahead
finish that point no because i'm going
to make a counterpoint tell me the
laundry list of things that you love
about swedish fish and why they're
better than animal crackers and my
defense to you is not even a word it's
this
okay
[Laughter]
finer things are worth effort
it's terrible
i hate it
it's my least favorite part about the
swedish fish it happens 100 of the time
the fish guts get stuck in between your
incisors and your chompers and all that
stuff dude okay and then you got to get
them out and if you don't they stick
their old jelly-like attached to you
like a goddamn barnacle i want to say
and then you gotta get in it's a it's a
must you have to get in you have to
every time you eat one you have to get
into a full service cleaning i want to i
want to point out something that one of
the fans said here
there are so many options for animal
crackers you got classic that's it there
are not options the fun ones with the
pink frosting are disgusting whoa whoa
whoa how are the options you just told
me that the swedish fish can do all
multi colors the minis
i don't know what i said was
the wow the swedish fish has good
options
or when i was looting what did you say
i go all right on swedish fish i don't
go with the options this guy's going oh
animal crackers are better because they
have options who the hell is eating the
pink frosting animal crackers those
things are disgusting i didn't know they
existed but i'm not going to not give
them a whirl
by the way
what is it pink
if a pink frosted lion takes a stroll in
front of me come on
give me a break and if you're talking
about the problem of picking out of your
teeth with swedish fish try eating four
animal crackers in a row with a glass of
water in front of you forget it dude you
feel like you just went through the
desert
it is brutal man it is brutal they
absorb every bit of moisture out of your
mouth every bit especially the ones that
come in the tub that just look like
saltines those that they cut into
animals they will not defend those all
right i will not defend those those are
terrible i'm talking about barnums
nabisco's barnums
uh cookies crackers over candy in
general that's what i'm saying
definitely in this case swedish fish are
all the same shape and rip your fillings
out yup
uh animals are in fact cookies the
swedish fish are neither sweat fish nor
edible who does not like
swedish fish
oh boys solidified sawdust in the shape
of what someone thinks animals look like
or jelly robitus and sardines i can't
decide uh you know what put a pin in
that one that might be the winner jelly
roll with dustin's sardines he's the
funniest thing all right so that's what
i'm saying too you're saying they both
stick in your teeth then
uh animal crackers don't as so much
stick in your teeth as suck every bit of
moisture out of your mouth and
where you're gonna choke like animal
crack let's put this away animal
crackers are not a bet in bed cookie you
can eat a chocolate chip cookie in bed
you can eat an oreo in bed yes you can
you pop em there's no mess
you will choke to death in your bed you
can't have those in your bed you need to
be able you need to be sitting up and
able to ingest fluids
this is an amazing matchup because both
share the exact same trait you always go
through the stages i don't know if i
want those i'll have a few holy [ __ ]
i've eaten more than the entire bowl i'm
disgusted with myself that being said i
have to go swedish fish all right
finally once call me crazy but i'd
rather have the red gunk on my teeth
than stale dinosaurs but you're eating a
stale box though swedish fish make you
want to go to ikea and get lost for
eternity
um i will tell you this uh
i will tell you i really love um the
i can't tell if there was pro fish or
against it i think bro right he's saying
he wants to move to sweden yeah i guess
sorry
uh
i i like the whole process of the animal
cracker and eating it first of all the
box with the string on it is a treat it
looks like a train there's animals on it
it's old school it's nostalgic
you got me on packaging when you go to
mcdonald's i'll bring up your beloved
mcdonald's right happy meal you love the
happy meal yeah the old hobby meals not
now not the [ __ ] ones now in a bag
but the old ones with the arches for
handles yeah
there's something about packaging this
packaging wallops any other packaging i
actually love that they still staple
that little white string on there they
don't it's got the handle now
that's a different i'm sure there's
different kinds you see the one right
next to it has it but that's the 100
birthday that's why
if you look at all the newer boxes it's
just the handle the 100th birthday was
2002. even with the handle that's fine
it's see i don't like that i like when
they keep the animals in the cage i
don't like that one see when they just
what they do they just now they're just
free roaming well they had the chickens
do they not keep well well i'll tell you
why they didn't no peter helped barnum
animals crackers
in the box i'll tell you why shall we
zebra
p.t barnum read up on the man he's a
bastard this is not a beloved american
icon the guy was horrible okay yeah so
you're celebrating a box of cookies that
celebrates a horrible man that
celebrates his horrible legacy by
putting these things in cages i mean you
go to the zoo they're in cages but he
was particularly bad with these animals
but f him man he's long dead they're
named after him but he's not getting
anything you think he's a state look at
the lies these sons of [ __ ] tell good
source of calcium
this is outrageous that they put stuff
like this on the box give me a break
but listen you got me on packaging you
win i can't even argue they always
switch the pack because this one the
other one had lion tiger uh yeah they
they switch it up that one's got a polar
bear
elephant
oh there it is there's a gorilla here
they come in little bags see they do put
them in bags too all right so can you go
back and
is that new or old animals set free on
the biscuit animal crackers box
antipedic complaints oh that's
ridiculous and i enjoy peter but that's
ridiculous
you can't celebrate this man
what year is this pimp what year
uh 2018. can you make it big
animals are now roaming
free on boxes nabisco's bar amazon for
the last three years i bet you those old
ones are now collectors items my friends
and i got you on i bet you this too what
there ain't no way peta tried to get the
animal cracker changed entirely because
even the concept of eating an animal is
offensive to them and the bisco went
pump the brakes peter you know what i
mean we'll give you the cages
we're not changing i don't think these i
don't think the biscuits should have
should have showed bad down to the cage
uh find something for me there pen
it doesn't say much that there was a
collaboration between the two just
scrolled to the very top then
but they're still in the cage on the bag
unless that's an old bag that's that
can't be that over the first paragraph
since 1902 boxes of barnum's animals
have been pictured tigers giraffes
zebras behind bars and circus cages now
nabisco pear and
deerfield mandalas international has
removed the cages uh people for the peta
had protested the cages depicted on the
boxes and the group sent a letter
to
mandalas in 2016 asking for the balls to
be removed
following discussions of peta in which
we suggested a new design the brand has
redesigned the packaging to show animals
free in nature instead of held captive
and cages for humanity you're reading so
fast remember when you yelled at me to
read slaughterhouses because i thought
you didn't want me to read this is what
i mean i was reading this remember
things that just happened i was reading
fast because i thought you were looking
at me like don't read anymore no
which you just you know literally going
like that
with everything right no no
yell at me today i can you're doing a
lot today you're doing a lot today
there's a lot to criticize what i was
saying don't make me hate you before you
were saying
okay all right all right the new box of
barnums reflects what our society no
longer tolerates caging and chaining
exotic animals for a circus show that's
not true
also i didn't see them chained
and also i just pictured it as i was
like sorry
go ahead
don't interrupt me i'm sorry i'll slap
you i said sorry i said sorry
you see that does that feel good
going zero to 100 and threatening
violence i didn't threaten violence you
said you'd hit me i said don't make me
hit you yeah that's threatening violence
that's not the threat that you forcing
me to hit you
okay i know this guy
a threat would be i'm gonna hit you
you making me do it i can't yeah that's
that's your decision
don't gaslight me but listen this is the
thing this is like when pearl jam fought
ticketmaster
right
and they were like because on the
tickets yeah they had all the band
members in cages right
do you remember that they tried to get
the fees taken off and they did this
whole long battle the ticketmaster was
like
uh pearl jam won the case 10 cents have
been removed from every ticket it was
like so negligible
at randall's island with their own
ticketing system and it was rough yeah
peter i agree with them i agree with
them takes too much money i agree too
but peta and i i partly agree with pete
on the circus thing but like peter's out
there trying to shut circus is down and
then in the end it's like
where's where are we at with that circus
thing we're like we got the uh
bars taking off the animal cracker boxes
so uh we want to talk to you about the
clubbing of the seals uh if i may before
we start the uh the meeting i just want
to follow up with something we've been
able to do a huge huge step has been
taken
the crackers are now free roaming
on the nabisco boxes continue about the
clubbing of the seals please
uh by the way the ringling brothers and
barnum bailey circus closed down in
2017.
so i bet you we're not far off from
these not being called barnum's crackers
anymore or are they or did they already
change that
pimp go back up to the new box
no it's still called barnum's animal i
guarantee these will be called animal
criminals
animals
crackers
yeah they were animal crackers barnum's
animals crackers
no but i never said that i always said
let's get animal crackers i think the
original are called animal crackers but
they probably changed it slightly well
that one sounds weird
animals crackers
the
product is called barnum's animals and
then the crackers is the description
no but it's barnum's animals crackers no
no i understand everything has an s at
the end of it i understand what i'm
saying to you is if you were to know why
isn't it barnum's animal crush i'm
explaining it to you if you if you were
just going to name this product properly
it would just be barnum's animals i want
a pack of barnum's animals please the
crackers is just there to be like look
they're crackers you see what i'm saying
okay because there's not a way to get
around being sued but nobody says
animals crackers
i know so
i know but i'm saying they're getting
around getting sued for not calling them
animal crackers they probably don't own
animal the term animal crackers oh you
think so yeah they didn't create animals
oh you know about law you know about
this copyright law better than that
adding an s to it doesn't change it the
change is still there
uh
you know you're talking about a law
what was that law back in 1902 or
whenever the hell they started making
these no the reason they're saying it
show is because of grammar
no it's not one animal it's multiple so
barnum's animals crackers that's why
they're saying it they're not doing it
to skirt a lawsuit i disagree you can't
why can't i disagree i'm just all i'm
pointing out is that
not only did i not realize that as much
as i like them but i never hear anyone
say i want to have some animals crackers
yes you're right it's also listed as
animal
yeah
i think it but all right well back in
the day i used to say barnum's animals
put original packaging guys i'm a
technology
i wouldn't say buff buff would would
imply some sort of intelligence but i'd
say a bit of a technology freak and i
use a lot of devices throughout the day
i'm on the pads and the tablets and the
laptops and the and the phones and the
smart things and everything else
uh and here's the thing it's important
to find the tools that fit your routine
so you can stay productive i'm using
these tools to help me most the time
with work sometimes with entertainment
ultimate ears
that's where they come in
it fits true ultimate ears fits true
wireless custom fit earbuds for ultimate
ears are here to change everything for
you custom fit earbuds what more could
you want to go along with all these
devices you're using and a lot of the
time you're using them in public so you
need to have earphones and all of the
years are different everyone's here is
different
so this is custom-made to your specific
ear yeah i can't stand i've bought
earbud pair after earbud pair
uh from different brands you know people
say wow this one is
this one is uh you know uh strobes
they're good you know that's why they're
800.
and you buy it and you go it doesn't fit
my ear right you know what i'm saying
yeah so i like that they're doing custom
thing uh and they also here's where
you're gonna get on a charge you're
gonna get eight hours of continuous
playback on a single charge and up to 20
hours with the charging case ultimate
ears fits are perfect for listening to
your favorite shows
like taste buds but here's the thing
this is the fun part you get a perfect
fit for your ear in a minute
right it'll stay put when you're on the
go but feel ultra comfortable so you can
wear them all day long without paint or
comfort they actually kind of warm up
when they're in there yeah and they
start to mold your ear it's a pretty
cool feeling you put them in you connect
to the app and watch the purple leds
form on the earbuds to your unique shape
you see it actually happening it's
really cool yeah i like that about them
because you know as comics we you have
to go on long flights frequently
and i've had earbuds where after an hour
or two you're going i can't you know
what i mean and then what are you
listening to that you're hearing the
baby cry nobody wants that right
you could also set your your custom
settings through the app
uh try fits today if you don't love them
as much as we do no worries ultimate
ears offers a 30-day
money-back guarantee plus you get your
free shipping and free returns and a
one-year warranty this is a good deal so
you're going to use the promo code
tastebuds at ue.com
fits
and you're going to get a pair of ue
fits for just 199. that's ue.com
fits promo code tastebuds all right
folks i'll tell you what let's keep it
fancy let's keep it fresh in this new
year of 2022. well keeping it fresh uh
peloton does that so i was going to tell
you we're talking about peloton and the
thing i like about peloton is the
variety
for me i don't like the the same
boring routine over and over in the gym
it feels like a lot of times when you're
really struggling in the gym it feels
like a take all day long so for me
something different and exciting i think
changing things up is key to me and
that's why
when i use the peloton it's great and
now they have new classes they have all
new music so different there's just
different ways to keep it fun you could
i like i like i love like
taking a flyer on a new class with a new
instructor and then seeing if i like
them or not and then whenever you like
someone it's always great i add them to
my favorites repetition can be what
kills you from continuing to stay on the
routine you need to stay on
i use the peloton app
which is also available
and i like using it quite a bit with the
exercise bike i own
you own an actual peloton bike which i
know you enjoy very much and it makes it
easy to stay motivated because there's
always new stuff to explore classes what
have you they have boxing now peloton is
stepping into the ring with a new
discipline no gloves needed discover
fast and furious and fun workout with
peloton instructors in your corner
there's new artist series music
selections always being added which i
love because i'm big into music if i'm
doing any sort of exercise agreed uh and
just more daily workout variety it makes
it easier to stick to your goals as we
keep saying when you keep your workouts
interesting peloton has a workout for
every day and every schedule destress
for a long day with 30 minutes of
strength
20 minutes of cardio or do a quick
15-minute total body class before work
anyway
go to
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n
dot com one peloton dot com
visit one pellet town.com to learn more
that's o and e p e l o t o n dot com
all right original packaging
yeah
they hit you with the blue
look at that look at that classic box
yeah so it sells for 87 so what i was
going to say is
so what i was going to say is this warms
my heart by the way i can't get past the
christmas tree ornament thing it makes
me think of a christmas story it makes
me think of like old christmas and
you're hanging these cardboard things
from the tree yeah i agree wow all right
swedish fish doesn't have that this is
what i'm gonna say that's what i was
going back to the you when you said you
got me on packaging i was getting into
something i like the experience of the
animal cracker too i mean yes i'm
carrying it on since i was a kid but
just to harm on what you said
it's the string and by the way i carry
it by the string
if i have animal crackers i don't carry
the box
i carry the last time you bought a box
of these things be honest it was
probably on a road trip or like
something like a late night uh like
convenience store raid or something it's
been a minute it's been a minute but i
like opening the back and i even love
that paper wax that's in there that you
kind of rip open wax paper
[Music]
[Laughter]
touche
touche all right
but
but it if yeah i guess i guess i was
saying paper first because it tears and
i thought it was like
not just waxy but you're a billion it's
the same yeah you're right
i also like dipping my hand in and not
knowing which animal is coming out and i
do think even though it's impossible
some animal shapes taste better than
others that's it stop it you do not
think that sounds no i know they don't
joke i'm just saying like in the process
of eating it i like to feel like oh
these are my favorites you know what i
mean it's it's this there's a this
this this something involved
you're just pounding the spaceship
listen to the whole description
everything that you just said and how
much you sound like a mental patient i
carry the box around by the string
and then i open the paper wax and
pretend in my head that they taste
different you sound insane what are you
talking about
i will say in hindsight in hindsight
that sounded crazy all i mean is that
like i like to pick favorites and i
never know who i'm getting so it's just
it's a little adventure of who i'm
getting and then and then there's
something i like better than others so
i'm like oh i like
you know what you ever get the five
pound uh thing of the butter cookies
and the tin yeah i'm not a big fan sure
but yeah a lot of them were butter
cookies they're all butter based cookies
some of them had like a pretzel shape
with fake salt on it that was really
sugar right some of them had that like
you know the circle one yeah the circle
one is everyone's favorite one yeah
everyone's because that's the one that
just tastes like the butter cookie how
is that how is that possible that could
be everyone's favorite because it's the
one that just tastes like the butter
there's a couple of others that that
just tastes like the butter cookie too
but that's everyone's favorite it's a
classic cookie it's a classic it's
because the shape the texture everything
i don't know what it is but they're all
the same right let me they're all the
same so when i reach into an animal
cracker box and i'm like oh i really
want to eat like
the hound or whatever the hell it is
right right i'm just saying the same
thing like you go for that circle i go
for the hound
fair enough
uh i will now speak on behalf of there's
no hound i know that the swedish fish
you mean the same exact fish over and
over how come swedish fish don't make
them all the different fish species how
about that i don't care i don't care
about the different fish species i'm not
a lunatic that has to pretend a
different shape takes anxiety as soon as
i bite into a swedish fish i'm getting
anxiety but but and i don't even have
filling i don't even have feeling
because i don't like the fact that i'm
gonna have to do maintenance on my teeth
seconds after i get to your being you're
you're you're listen listen all good
things take effort and work it's a it's
a small price to pay for the glory of
the swedish fish and i'll tell you why
apply all good things take heart
[Music]
but but here's the thing here's where
the swedish fish destroys the animal
cracker ready
it is an undefinable flavor of an exotic
overseas berry that people have debated
what is it is it this is that it is the
most unique flavor of candy that is out
there because of the berry that it's
based on does not exist in this country
as far as i know if i understood that
correctly
animal cracker you want animal crackers
i'll make you some give me some graham
crackers and leave them out leave them
out on the couch
leave them out on the counter for a week
you can't go wrapping and then when they
start to go stale and get soft that's
what hannibal crackers are you can't
even do a hello fresh meal you're gonna
bake animal crackers from scratch no
we're going to make barley i didn't say
that
no no did you hear what i just said i
said you take graham crackers any graham
cracker leave it on the counter top let
it get soft and stale like it will get
after a week and then cut it into the
shape of a monkey and that's what an
animal cracker is they're stale graham
crackers it's not stale they're still
ground crabs stale if they're stale it's
not stale to begin with they're that
they're that soft style i'll leave
swedish fish out out in the open air for
a couple hours and they become hard as a
rock it ain't changing nothing but it
comes hard you leave that in a tempered
climate it'll last months no not not
after years
absolutely there is a soft swedish fish
and there is a hard swedish fish and
when you open that package and it's not
sealed again they get hard not hard like
a rock rock candy but they get way
harder than the consistency that's
supposed to be they literally it's a
real chore eating them though it's a
chore all right why do i want to sign up
for a chore because it's delicious
detroit and king crab legs it's amazing
yeah but at the end i'm getting alaskan
king crab legs the end of this you're
getting the best candy out there swedish
fish there's a millionaire by the same
people that makes sour patches there's a
million other kids candy out there you
lost in that match didn't you yeah yeah
but i was right i was right you lost two
skittles
skittles
well you know
i think starburst can take patch kids as
well i love starburst you name it all my
hits starburst
it could if you don't know what you're
doing become a maintenance candy but
before it gets stuck you got to roll it
around and so it doesn't get stuck it's
a maintenance candy period you've got to
unwrap every single bite
that's your question why am i going for
a swedish fish if there's a million
other candies out there that won't get
stuck in my teeth because they're
delicious
that's it what do you mean why why am i
getting king crab when there's a million
other delicious things on the menu i
can't eat a bag of swedish fish i can
have a few all right i can eat a bit you
can eat a full bag of swedish fish let
me tell you a swedish fish story please
for my childhood yeah tell me one i
played intramural basketball when i was
a kid i was terrible
uh so the really the only high point of
the game was whatever school we played
at the snack bar offer sure right
i'm there one day
this kid is he's got a brown bag like
one of those lunch bags and it's it's
greasy on the bottom
and he's eating something i can't see
he's eating i go what's in that bag man
and he goes he went to them and he goes
fish self-serve he goes fish
and i go
that's weird that they're selling fish
at the thing that's gross sure i don't
want fish and then when i realized he
meant swedish fish
i
i darted i've never run so fast to get
candy in my life
i was so excited swedish fish are such
an amazing treat
halloween that you know what they say
10th most popular halloween candy when
you got that in your bag on halloween it
was so exciting when you see those in
the theater you're gonna sit down with
them with that theater box of them it's
awesome and they're delicious the flavor
never gets old it's the same reason why
i can eat a whole bag of twizzlers the
flavor does not get old to me how dare
you call that a swedish fish story
why there was no story there that was
the whole story rewind the tape
the tape was that you were a kid and you
saw another kid eating something out of
a bag you thought it was fish and he
corrected you and then you ran towards
him to have one that is nice i ran into
the snack bar to get my own but that's
not a story joe yes it is no that's not
speaks to how excited i was about that
if that's the story then every moment of
everyone's life is a story well yeah
it might not be a good story i'm going
to tell you a little story about the
time that i was talking about swedish
fish a moment ago was that a good story
for you
like i said it might not be a good story
but it's a story but you but the way you
said it you said
let me tell you a little story about
swedish did that on purpose
i know and then i said
and then i said please tell me it
because i can't believe you had a
swedish fish story and then you told me
nothing yeah nothing happened i know
what i did
you found out somebody was eating
swedish fish and you went and got
yourself some
i was not interested when i thought it
was real fish
is the twist
let's read some more phone comments
getting a box of animal crackers as a
kid with such a treat i remember holding
the little string attached to the box
running them over to the tv to eat them
and watch cartoons that is a very good
memory i love that
oh my god i had swedish fish for the
first time at christmas and if sex was
candy it would be swedish fish
definitely
worth swallowing i didn't know that was
going there i got it what the hell is
swedish fish ooh
yummy gummy type candy somebody
responded with
so
it's a fight between boredom and
diabetes guess i'll go with this i
really don't think animal crackers is
boredom i think they're fun by the way i
haven't even talked about no way that
that's fake right
okay by the way it's one vote it says
one vote okay um
also could you imagine also though um
i didn't even bring up the milk
component
i love dunkin animal crackers i think
any type of gram goes the best with milk
that's my favorite cookie in milk
chocolate chip or gram
and it's fun because you dunk the
animals in the milk
it's just fun
i i don't give a rap i've told you all
first i told you this numerous times i
bite the legs off sometimes first i've
told you numerous times sometimes they
take out two animals and they make them
talk to each other i have a little scene
a little scene will play out like i'll
take out a giraffe and a zebra and the
zebra like let me tell you a little
story about swedish fish
i'll tell you something
i've said it many times in the show i
don't give a rat's ass about dunking i
could count on one hand the number of
times i've dunked a cookie into anything
i don't care about dunking i don't like
drinking milk
so
and and but if i did but if i did the
the animal cracker is not a good dunk
cookie it neat you need the milk to to
drink or you need some fluid to drink as
i said because they're so damn dry but
they're not a good dunking cookie
they're not enhanced at all but it's not
like with the oreo or the chocolate chip
cookie why because
dude it's a graham cracker that's all it
is i don't know why ram stockers are
amazing to dunkin milk i disagree i
disagree why would you disagree with
that it's such an easy thing to agree
with um i don't think they're amazing to
dunkin milk i think something needs a
little chocolaty to to bump up against
that milk that's my opinion you know
what i like to do too i put two animals
back to back so as to have like a double
animal the girth of a double animal then
i'll dip that in the milk and it's a
little bit more substantial
and it's like having a double bite this
is all there's all there's so many
different ways to eat an animal cracker
uh somebody said i animal crackers
stopped appealing to me once i turned
five years old i agree with that very
much it's not why it's it's just
packaging sir shall you inside
as a man in your 40s buying a box with a
little handle on it no you don't want to
eat animal crackers out no you don't
it's nuts if someone walked into a store
and i saw if i saw a person online
buying a box of animal crackers i
wouldn't be like this person looks like
a lunatic you can't buy a food that
looks like you're supposed to be
skipping as you hold it in your 40s i
can and i will and i'll tell you another
thing i may skip
i like skipping
swedish was the last time you skipped uh
i don't think i've ever skipped in my
life to be honest with you big surprise
though you know what i actually believe
that even though i don't have you ever
skipped of course i've skipped yeah
everyone has skipped joe have you
skipped i'm sure you can really think
about it i'm sure at one point i did
have you ever skipped
because if you haven't that's really
fascinating because i also do i have a i
also can't imagine him skipping i could
see him skipping around that big ditch
i'm sure yeah
yeah i'm sure as a kid i learned how to
skipped and i did it i mean but like all
right so i don't have a gift i don't
have skipping memories like i have bike
memories right but i mean i know for a
fact immediately i've skipped if i was
if i was on trial with with a with a
panel of senators right now and i was
asked this question i would say i cannot
answer that question with certainty
senator okay all right okay well let me
tell you something now i actually might
pay money of you skipping
i want to i want to make a gif of you
skipping
all right i it just goes against your
whole persona yeah it's it's an action
that goes to against an enemy
you know what i like to do for exercise
next time you well well it's hard to
just skip in a city street but if i was
like going my car in a parking lot or
something
i'll skip all the way to the car
because it's a workout people i don't
know why skipping's not uh like included
in workouts interesting yeah like
calisthenics you should start the skip
movement the skip movement yeah it's
even good that's even getting the skip
movement
uh
this is an interesting point
that this guy brings up animal crackers
are the cheerios of the snack world so
basic and bland only children enjoy them
swedish fish are just the flavor red
which everyone knows the red ones are
the best flavor of any candy no need to
attach any fruit to it just red all
right let it be known animal crust
crackers are frosted i will change my
vote quick
the animal crackers are frosted i will
cheat but but i mean i i can't tell you
the last time i even saw oh yeah the
swedish fish gum is so good i forgot
about that
that's see this is another great point
in in favor of swedish fish their flavor
is getting into other foods which means
the flavor is no joke there is not one
animal cracker flavored anything you
don't know that show i knew you were
going to say that sentence and you don't
know it i was about to say like i'm
surprised animal crackers has been
teamed up with like an ice cream like
all right let's see if it is pimp put
animal cracker flavored animal cracker
flavored uh
uh foods or whatever you know products
it's just animal crackers
what was the first thing scroll up pimp
captain crunch blue maple syrup whoa
what the hell is that
yeah let's see if animal crackers are
around more crocodiles you typed in
animal cracker products i'm saying it
could be a favorite product oh come on
all right put in animal cracker ice
cream
you know it doesn't exist we've never
seen it there was
circus cookie circus animals floating
hold on a second hold on that is that
but that's not talking like these are
common products you see everywhere wait
the circus cookies are legitimately the
animal crackers
original circus animal cook that's those
are just animal crackers
to the left is one product that put them
into ice cream great value ice cream
girl it's cold
no no there it is
great value ice cream is it okay there
you go there's your there's your yeah
babe you're going against trident oreos
right now with look
it's all over look it's all over good
value ice cream
no churn animal cracker ice cream
i mean it's a great idea
no it's not
it's a terrible idea it's disgusting
it's disgusting it's disgusting crackers
are good by the way if we did um if we
did cookies versus candy have you ever
done that what do you think would win we
did cookies versus uh cake right but if
we did cookies versus candy what do you
think would win uh i think cookies would
win i'll go i'm team kelly i think
cookies is updated with christmas pizza
and chicken fried chicken i'll go team
candy if you want to do that battle i'll
go team candy you heard it here first
first folks and i think and you lost
with cookies don't forget so you want to
take cookies
yes you did i did yes you did so you
want to take cookies to the mat again i
will let's go babe i will do it let's go
and i'll facebook
the reason i would do that is because i
think cookies would dominate candy and
here we have just a microcosm of that
battle
i think the cookie is better than candy
all right so listen you heard it here
folks we're gonna do it pimp if you
could make a note of it somewhere
cookies versus candy will happen very
soon uh our winning tweet was the
diabetes tweet
oh no i'm sorry this sort of sorry
oh boy solidified sawdust in the shape
of what someone thinks animals look like
or jelly robitus sardines i can't decide
follow mo energy podcast mo energy
podcast
uh all right pimp we gotta almost we're
approaching 12 000 votes
okay it's going humble pie segment drum
roll it here we go oh yeah at the time
we had time yeah yeah i mean yeah okay
we're at time pimp looks like he's gonna
choose animal crackers we got 12 000
votes humble pie segment let's put those
up
oh
give me a break oh
baby
oh
give me a break the boy is back babe
give me a brew wins then two wins and
52.1
you're under five percent it's under
five that's rematch territory that's
rematch crackers wins it 52.1 to 47.9
swedish fish and i'll tell you whenever
it's that close
it was a good matchup that's proved
positive that was a good match
all right
oh babe are you kidding me just say the
words
just i'm just saying say the words don't
quote just say the word say the words
come see me at the beacon theater may
14th in new york city tickets are on
sale right now march 11th i'm at the
ryan commercial already on the episode i
just want to tell the beacon special
the beacon is special
i know i still love you babe
i love you
too taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man